*music*
a question
that everyone is asking
what's it like to date PewDiePie?
today is your lucky day, because that's what we're gonna find out here today
Date PewDiePie Simulator
it's a game made by malcom_1466,
(a prufessional developer)
and his girlfriend
...Jessica.
that name..
sounds...
familiar
(Jessica creep talks)
where have i heard that name before?
(Jessica creep talks again)
- anyway, let's play it!
okay, so we will get points for how we answer.
*grammar pls*
all right, here we go.
"where you take him?"
water zoo
great wall of china
nickelback concert
*laughs* vidcon
c'mon, we need 100 points
which one is it?
Ireland
*ding-a-ling* 100 POINTS!
'cause you can visit a real man like "jacksepticeys"
*fuck you*
i already hate this quiz.
"what you are wearing for him?"
something light and frilly,
hatsune miku cosplay,
swedish flag track suit
is that a thing?
'cause i need that right now.
gonna buy 10 of them (omg)
uuhh -- anyway
i see a lot of fans wearing hatsune miku cosplays so,
i'm gonna go with hatsune miku cosplay.
0 points. "Felix is racist".
WELL GODDAMMIT..!
this doesn't prove anything.
how many points do we have?
100 points
we have 100 points.
"what food will you order for Felix to eat??"
what the fuck?
is this a sentence?
can you fuckin' learn proper english?
we will eat ikea meatballs.
i don't even have to read the rest..
5 points.
"they are disgusting but he will like it".
now listen here..
how fuckin' dare you?
"what music will you play for Felix in the car?"
*laughs*
is that evanescence?
*trying to pronounce malcolm language*
okay, we will go with *evanescence*
5 points -
"'cause he needs to wake up and kill himself."
fu -
why are you so mean?
*wake me up inside plays*
okay well i'll take
what *burps* 5 points?
thank you very much.
"what will you do to him at your home?"
nothing,
hold hands and prayer,
kiss him
sex him,
sex him hard.
..sex him hard!
5 points.
*laughs* "this could kill him."
how fuckin' dare you?
sex him.
"bitch would cry and not become erect".
wow.
"what about after the sex?"
"call him a cab! send that bitch home!"
wtf is that picture.. of Bella?
that's really cool..
"ask his number from him?"
let him stay over the night,
sex him again,
slaughter him and his entire bloodline.
50 points.
what the fuck is that?!
you calling me a rac-
- what
if you have the chance, no matter the risk,
you must attempt to kill this asshole dead forever. he is cancer.
*wake me up inside plays again*
okay, maybe we should ask his number from him.
5 points.
screenshot his texts for Keem. (keemstar)
i mean..
that seems possible.
120 points.
get Keem on the dm's.
why?
"you probably got some nice juicy shit to try"
"and ruin Felix's life with! Great job!"
"but could have been better..."
"you are the chosen one. the dark sun risen again."
"to save us all from the aids that is PewDiePie's channel"
"i have freed your mind but i can only show you the door."
you're the one who must walk through it.
what the fu-
this quiz was made by malcolm_1466
congratulations disciples.
we have completed phase 2 and he has no idea..
i mean.. you just told me..
dillon has distracted him long enough.
what the fuck?
soon we strike.
phase 3. the killing blow. (no homo)
is jessica in on this?
no
wtf
that was the video. leave a like if you enjoyed,
and if you did, leave a like and also.. (never forget) don't forget to leave a like if this video hits more than
2 likes.
ha ha ha ha ha *inhales*
it's funny 'cause i'll probably get like 100s and 100s of thousand
but at least i didn't call out the likes in the beginning of the video
like a fucktard
asking for likes
give me likes
NOW.
NEED
MORE
FUCKING
like, leave a like, don't forget to leave a like.
and subscribe
and leave a like
thank you for liking.
brofi- brolike *brofist*
o k